[Music]
coming up next on book notes an in-depth
look at the pentagon's budget our guest
is tim weiner washington correspondent
for the philadelphia enquirer and author
of blank check the pentagon's black
budget this book is based on his
pulitzer prize winning series for the
philadelphia inquirer it examines the
pentagon's spending priorities and
explores the need for secret operations
in an open society
[Music]
tim weiner
what is the
pentagon's black budget
it's the pentagon's own term for
every program
that the secretary of defense the
director of central intelligence or the
president of the united states wants to
keep off the books
wants to keep deleted from the public
budget of the pentagon
and kept at a classification of top
secret or above
these are the secret weapons
and the secret policies for combating
the cold war
and world war three
and should it come to that
world war iv
who calls it the black budget the
pentagon originated the term the term
black comes from
the world of espionage and means like a
black bag job undercover
hidden from light secret
when did you first hear the term
the term
my newspaper sent me down to washington
that is what newspaper the philadelphia
inquirer
in april of 1986
and the idea was to get behind some of
the stories we'd been hearing during the
months proceeding about the
fantastically expensive hardware
the uh
thousand dollar wrenches the six
thousand dollar coffee pots and so forth
uh
i obtained a copy of the budget of the
pentagon
and
leaf through the uh
sections detailing research and
development and procurement programs the
budgets for buying new weapons
there are blank spaces
hundreds of them
where dollar figures should be
there were code words where descriptions
or names of programs should be
i began talking to people inside and
outside of the pentagon
and they identified this as a problem
a problem
in a kind of a tug of war between
secrecy and democracy
i don't mean to over dramatize it but
that spring things were getting out of
hand in washington
and
you had an atmosphere that secrecy was
winning
the folks i talked to focused my
attention on the black budget and i went
to work philadelphia in choir why were
they i mean you have a it's owned by
knight ritter you have a big washington
bureau why would they send you down to
washington to do something that they're
already doing well they weren't
um
and uh
the
editor of the newspaper who's sadly left
us recently gene roberts
was very intrigued by the notion
it wasn't something that was being
directly addressed and he wanted me to
dig up as much as i could and get it in
the paper
before i had assembled enough to write
about iran contrabroke
that fall
and so the context of excessive secrecy
was now something that was on the public
agenda how long had you been in
philadelphia at the time i started work
for the inquiry in 1982 so
most of that time was digging into
corruption and hud programs
corruption in the philadelphia police
department and i just returned from four
months in the philippines covering the
marco san aquino contest where's home
originally
new york my folks moved to california
when i was a teenager they teach at ucla
and they brought me up to love words
love books love ideas what do they teach
my dad's field is psychosomatic medicine
and my mom's is history where'd you go
to school
columbia college in new york
and then the graduate school of
journalism at columbia
when did you go originally to journalism
right after your master's degree yep
where i started out
working three jobs simultaneously in new
york based in the federal and state
courts there down in foley square
and
this is where i learned my love of
documents
when you interview people
as a reporter
sometimes they will lie sometimes they
will equivocate or shade their speech
to suit
a private agenda but the document like
the lawyers say speaks for itself
were you a good student in college
pretty good
so you liked you liked uh the idea of
digging in the stacks for the document
that contains the seed of fact
is integral to good journalism
the idea of coming up with
uh
words on paper or facts on file
that will give you the underpinnings
the historical basis
for writing
good interpretive analytical work that
started in college that started in the
stacks how old are you 34 now and you've
already got two pulitzer prizes well uh
a group of uh
us at the kansas city times shared a
pulitzer 1982 for uncovering the causes
of the hyatt hotel disaster that
happened in the summer of 1981 the
collapse of the skywalks in a brand new
hotel that killed 114 people
so that was a
shared one and then these stories that
formed the basis of blank check were
given the pulitzer for national
reporting in 1988
at 30 that was 32. you were 32 years old
and you got a pulitzer your second
pulitzer does that has that had a
what's that do to your head
well the best thing that happened was
that when my name got in the paper old
friends i hadn't heard from in years
called me up and
that was the best thing that happened i
think that
you run the danger of egomania and
certainly i'm afflicted with that
disease but
you have to realize that
the symbology of a prize like that you
shouldn't confuse
what the thing is represents with the
meaning of your work
i just try to write good stories and get
them in the paper
okay you're addressing a bunch of
college kids and they know you've got
two pulitzer prize prizes at this age
step outside your own body if you can
and observe what is it that you have
been able to do that's different that
got you these prizes
in college
and in the graduate school
i had a few good teachers who put a few
basic values
into my head and said set of fire
burning in my belly
the
dictums of
i have stone and of lincoln stefan's
that one should try and get at the roots
of social and political problems
with first-hand research
and
by not believing or at least taking with
a large grain of salt
the official version of events
has always driven me and i think it
drives all reporters who keep their eye
on the ball
a reporter without certain basic values
is a stenographer
who simply repeats and amplifies
the
official words of officialdom and that
is less
than
the minimum work at minimum we should be
rooting out
hidden facts and presenting them to
people so they can make their own minds
up about how their government works
you say in your book that
a hundred
million dollars a day
is available to the president of the
united states as secretary of defense
the director of cia and the agencies
over which they preside
without accountability to the american
people
that's true
this is a system that began
when the cold war took root in this
country
and one of the ironies of the cold war
as we look back
is that our open rambunctious
contentious democracy
took on a few of the attributes of the
sullen and secretive and closed society
with which we were at war
in the
atmosphere of emergency
in 1949 1950
the nation decided that it would be best
to
establish permanent secret agencies
in this country
foremost of which was the cia
and that the money to run the cia
should be appropriated
secretly
and should not be
questioned in effect that the director
of the cia would get a lump sum of money
approved by one or two or three or four
members of congress and that he did not
have to account for
uh how that money was spent what this
meant
in practice
was that the agency could
hire armies it could buy banks
without accounting to anyone
in
its
uh prosecution of the secret war against
the soviet union
what happened in the 1980s
was that the pentagon
began to bury its largest and most
expensive
weapons technologies
under the cover originally designed
for the intelligence community
uh two examples that have sort of nosed
their way into the light now
developed under the black budget on the
stealth bomber the nuclear b2 bomber
and a satellite system called milstar
whose aggregate costs
if completed
will approach 100 billion dollars
there was an obsession with secrecy
that caused the black budget to explode
in the early 1980s
and it doubled and doubled again
to the point where we were
by the close of the reagan
administration
spending 36 billion dollars a year or
roughly 100 million dollars a day
outside the normal channels of
accountability let me ask you does
senator did senator sam nunn and
congressman les aspen respective
chairman on each side of the congress
over here know about this black budget
absolutely
but they couldn't talk about it
debate
open debate was curtailed
on these secret weapons systems and in
fact my first week of reporting down in
washington
les aspen put out the first public
statement
on the growth of the black budget back
in april of 1986 and he said that secret
weapon spending
as the pentagon budget doubled from 1981
to 1985 had gone up eightfold
and that
it was to use his term his words grossly
excessive and that this was information
that ought to be available in a
democracy
sure aspen knew what the stealth model
was going to cost but he couldn't tell
his colleagues nor could the question be
debated on the floor how many people in
congress know about the black budget and
no no the specifics of the black budget
to have an effective overview enough to
make intelligent rational decisions
at minimum eight
are
given access to
every
jot and tittle that they need
um you mean if you're a junior member of
the senate armed services committee
senator you can get it most of it you
can get most of it or you could go to
none and ask for
a briefing do they have to testify
on capitol hill that they want this
money to build the b-2
uh well now they do because
in the beginnings in the in the
beginnings of the stealth bomber program
there were four members of congress
who knew what the plane was supposed to
cost and who knew technical details
about it
uh
now that now of course the stealth is
into the light and we can see
that what we've got
is a bomber
designed for nuclear war against the
soviet union
that is so expensive that you could have
built each 70-ton plane out of solid
gold
and still had enough money left over to
mount it on a bed of platinum
had open debate
been permitted
before the stealth bombers started
rolling off the production line
i think it would have been beneficial
for this country okay let's go to the uh
by the way do you live in washington
yes indeed you get caught by a potomac
fever
i don't see myself as part of the
washington community
i see myself as
a reporter from out of town
who is
standing aside and observing
the workings of government
i can think of some of my colleagues who
work for
washington
institutions like the post
um
who i believe see themselves as kind of
the fourth estate as part of the
workings of government
um
i disagree with that approach
so what happens when you welcome the
pentagon do they when they see you
coming down the hallway nothing
how do they treat you they know who you
are no they don't
and no one's ever said you know look out
boy get back
um
i tend to work from the documents
that the pentagon puts out to use the
public record to get it something deeper
the public record to use what's public
or what's been declassified
taking apart the pentagon's budget to
determine what's black what secret is
kind of a reverse engineering
for example
if you want to know the level of secret
spending in the research and development
budget you've got a bottom line let's
say it's
50 billion dollars
you add up the several thousand
unclassified line items and you'll see
that there's a 10 billion dollar gap
there
so you know the 10 billion dollars is
being funneled out
into secret spending from there you
[Music]
get to a deeper level by interviewing
people who have or have had access to
this information
and doing a great deal of reading as to
the nuclear strategy and um
technological goals that the pentagon is
pursuing i wanted to ask you about a
line that popped out of the pages of
your book i could be charged with a
felony for telling you
i thought this was a free country where
you can talk about anything in the first
in the first amendment protection
uh there are
code word classification levels
and the programs discussed in that
passage which are for strategic nuclear
warfare olympic bellwether meridian
bernie
in the reign of director casey of the
cia he threatened
uh more than a few reporters with felony
prosecutions under the espionage
statutes
for revealing code word programs
i'd seriously doubt
that
such a prosecution could be successfully
mounted
because of the first amendment
protections but there remain statutes on
the book that the government interprets
as protecting
code word classified information
and
they are effective statutes they're on
the books they're there is it scary
enough not to publish it no sir
no sir i think the first amendment is
stronger
in the back under acknowledgements and
you talk about coming to washington and
not being a part of it here
but you do thank some people yes
and let me read the list and i want you
to tell me if you can't who they are in
washington i received guidance from
dina razor
and donna martin both formally with the
project on military procurement
that is uh the organization that first
dug up the raw information on the
extraordinary
items that the pentagon was producing
such as the
coffee pots the wrenches the hammers
and they do
and have in the past done tremendous
cost analysis
of how the pentagon produces its weapons
they have a network of people inside the
pentagon who help them gather
information where do they come from
they are a privately funded and
apolitical
group and they range from cheap hawks
that is people on the right of the
spectrum who want the defense dollars
spent efficiently
to doves who want
the defense dollar spent
uh
in
more pacific and perhaps in less
substantial ways why would anybody want
to spend money for that purpose and what
kind of money do they get
i i don't know i think they're
independently funded
from various organizations like ford
foundation or maybe stuart lott i really
haven't looked behind their financing
but they're a respected institution i
don't know you know this but why are
they both formally of that project well
let's see donna went to work for a
member of congress and dina
i believe is uh now freelance author
did you find them or did they find you
oh i went to them and they put me onto
some wonderful people inside the
pentagon
ernest fitzgerald a ernest fitzgerald
you think who is ernie fitzgerald one of
uh the pentagon's most famous and
staunchest in-house critics this is the
man who in the early 1970s was fired
upon the order of president nixon
because from his post as a cost analyst
inside the pentagon he identified the
first billion dollar cost overrun in
pentagon history on the c5 cargo plane
where is he now he is still inside the
pentagon he was reinstated by order of
the federal courts do they watch the
kind of people that he talks to
i believe under the court order
reinstating him uh he is protected from
harassment
and he was helpful to you yes
what kind of help can he give you
the benefit of his his experience
guidance on
how to see weapon systems
ernie once explained
to a wrapped congressional committee
that they should see
an expensive military aircraft for
example the stealth bomber
not as a single unit but as a
collection of vastly overpriced spare
parts flying in tight formation
and it is images like that
that allow
outsiders to gain a greater
understanding of how the pentagon works
there's another gentleman here by the
name of thomas emily tom emily has been
with the department of defense for
nearly 40 years
he is a highly talented weapons designer
he designed the sidewinder a lethally
effective air-to-air missile
and he is also
a skeptic
on the subject of black programs
uh my first week in washington through
the the uh
good offices of dina razor i was
introduced to tom emily we sat down at
the pentagon cafeteria i asked him about
the problem of black programs and he
said i'm paraphrasing but
he said look there are three reasons for
having black programs this is a man with
some access to this information
one you're doing something that should
genuinely be secret there's about five
of them and stealth ain't one of them
two you're doing something so stupid
that you don't want anybody to know
about it and three you want to rip open
the money bag get out a big shovel
because there's no accountability for
this money
and uh
i remember his words vividly is he angry
i think tom amley is a classic example
of a patriot
and he does not want the defense dollar
squandered
on wild-eyed schemes
or on impossible missions
or on screwball goals
he is a man who has spent his adult life
dedicated to the defense of this country
and what uh he stands against
are boondoggles
particularly boondoggles protected
under a
national security shield he's a
government employee he is he works for
the air force would he be allowed under
the rules of the pentagon to come here
and do a television program with us sure
thing
if you ask him about what's black
he might have to bite his tongue
uh but uh he'd be more than happy
on this list you have john pike of the
federation of american scientists why
could they be of help to you pike is an
expert in the
overhead reconnaissance systems
the spy satellites
run by an agency called the national
reconnaissance office
which officially does not exist the
united states government has never
acknowledged
uh its existence and it is forbidden to
mention the name
of this agency on the floor of the
congress how do you know about it
um
well through people like john pike and
their good offices in fact
what cannot be mentioned on the floor of
the congress can be written about and in
fact a
journalist and professor named william
burroughs
several years ago wrote a very sober and
sympathetic book about the nro it's
called black why can you write about it
but members of congress can't speak
about it because i thought they had the
you know the uh the right to say
anything they want to do on them they
shall not not be uh
held accountable right for what they say
on the floor brought to law
because the united states government has
never acknowledged the existence of the
national reconnaissance office
a member who mentions its name on the
floor of the house
can be subject to sensor in fact
when congressman george e brown jr of
california
dared to question some of the nro's
spending
he came within a hair's breath of
official censure he resigned from the
house intelligence committee
uh this is simply not done how much
money do they spend roughly seven to
eight billion dollars a year
and this stuff needs to be debated let
me give you an example why
a few weeks back you remember
the hubble space telescope a 1.5 billion
dollar nasa
program
experienced some technical difficulties
in space
well that's a subject of important
debate and uh we need to make sure that
such mistakes aren't repeated all right
around the same time a 1.3
billion dollar national reconnaissance
office satellite
tumbled out of orbit burned up over
soviet airspace and disintegrated you'll
hear no debate about it
you won't see any public investigation
of that
expensive mistake because of the secrecy
surrounding the national reconnaissance
office how much press has there been
about it damn little
little shirt tails
how come
because public information
on
the expenditures of public funds or what
were public funds and have been hidden
under the black umbrella is curtailed
what's that term you just used shirt
tails oh a shirt tale is a little uh
additional uh story of three paragraphs
or so at the end of a larger newspaper
story it's sort of an oh by the way
in the story are separate separate
little separate sub headline
all right on the list here you have
gordon adams and stephen alexis kane of
the defense budget project what did they
do for you right around the corner um
these are
folks who've devoted their careers to
doing cost analysis of pentagon programs
they're nonpartisan
they are
working for more efficient spending of
the defense dollar
and they were expert in pentagon
budgeting
processes and they provided me again
with the benefit of their experience
where they get their money i believe
again they're funded by non-partisan
foundations what makes them so expert
experience where do they get the
experience
from years of taking apart pentagon
budgets and analyzing them
any of them ever worked inside the
pentagon or do you need to in order to
understand this stuff
i think it helps and and they certainly
are in contact with a number of people
inside the pentagon who give them
guidance in turn
um
i think what you need is a clear eye
a pocket calculator
and a sense of history for starters
um i've got some others i want to ask
you about
you paint a picture of a pentagon full
of people that are on the phone
every day to these different groups
giving them insider information
no it doesn't work that way again these
folks work as i worked
with
the public documents of the pentagon
it's not a matter of sort of leaking
information that should be classified
you simply analyze
what's public
and proceed to ask questions from there
and
folks who will give you answers
do so not out of a desire to
you know uh
spread secrets or
do damage certainly to this country
certainly not but out of a genuine
concern
that large sums of money are going down
a rat hole
and in this instance
what i try to focus on in the early
chapters of the book
are the secret research and development
and procurement
of nuclear war technologies
of
the uh
equipment with which to fight and the
pentagon presumes win a nuclear war
again your premise is that 36 billion
dollars a year in the last three years
of the reagan administration the first
year or two of the bush administration
is being hidden from the american people
and spent on weapons in the defense
department oh and on the intelligence
budget
um what's the cia budget every year the
cia's budget is running in the 4 billion
dollar range it
is that budget is dwarfed
by two much larger and much more
expensive
intelligence agencies the national
security agency
which conducts electronic eavesdropping
around the world and whose budget
is in excess of 12 billion dollars a
year and the national reconnaissance
office that we talked about whose budget
runs in excess of seven eight billion
dollars a year in there
um
all in all
the budget for
intelligence
is in excess of 25 billion dollars a
year
the remainder of the black budget in the
10 billion range is for
weapons and war technologies how much of
that 25 billion can be seen in a budget
in the federal budget set up by the
president any of it not a line
how much of it is ever discussed
publicly
at the congress in one way or the other
very very little
how many members of congress know about
25 billion being spent on intelligence
the
heads of the senate intelligence
committee and of the house intelligence
committee have a good overview of how
that money is spent
uh the
junior members uh generally are in on
when they have time for it because these
are busy people
whatever testimony the folks from the
various agencies deliver in closed
session
isn't that the way democracy is supposed
to work in closed session absolutely not
public officials elected by the public
sent here to do the public's business
know this information deal with it in
committee but it's because of our
concerns about
international governments knowing this
kind of stuff that they withhold from
the public again i do not argue in this
book and no one in his right mind would
argue
that the constitution demands the
disclosure of intelligent sources or
methods
nor do i argue that the pentagon should
be compelled to disclose technologies
it's working on
or state-of-the-art designs
but the money
is supposed to under the scheme devised
by the framers of the constitution be
reported to the public
with the intelligence budget
in the past three different sort of
commissions or investigative bodies have
looked at this question
the rockefeller commission set up by
president ford in the wake of cia abuses
being disclosed
uh the senate intelligence committee
and the church committee that looked
into various abuses of secret spending
in the 70s
all concluded that the disclosure of a
lump sum
an aggregate sum for the national
intelligence budget would a not harm
national security
and b
is the kind of information that ought to
be available in an open democracy
when it comes to weapons systems the
line items
for individual weapons systems that is
surely information that ought to be
available to us and les aspen who's
hardly a wild-eyed leftist
is on record disagreeing with that
you say he's a hardly a wild left is
he's a democrat from wisconsin true
that doesn't make him uh some sort of
radical
i said he's hardly a wild eyed leftist
he's he's this is a man who is in the
mainstream of american politics less
aspen used to work in the pentagon i
believe he did as a matter of fact
worked for secretary of defense mcnamara
in the 60s he's an economist by
profession the man knows the value of a
defense dollar
you've got some more people want to ask
you about sure
the last three jeffrey
richelson richelson
jeff nason sure and steve gulster
of the national security archive now
this is a fascinating
depository of declassified documents
that's an invaluable resource to
researchers in washington
um again set up excuse me with
foundation money
it
functions for example say i get
several thousand pages of declassified
documents through the
freedom of information act
i after
plundering them for whatever information
i want
can give them to the national security
archive and then other researchers and
historians and reporters
have access to those papers and what the
archive does
is in effect collate and index
the declassified documents of the
government
in a way that
really is unique
it
will be of great value to future
historians of this era
who pays the bill for the national
security archive again they received
funding from organizations like although
i'm not positive uh the
ford foundation uh
stuart mott sort of uh good government
uh
philanthropies and uh what's the
expertise of the three people of steve
gulster uh jeff nathan and jeffrey
richelson archivists
indexers researchers richelson is uh has
been a professor of government at
american university and has written half
a dozen excellent books
on the structure and history of american
intelligence agencies
what do you say to the critics on the
right that are going to read that list
and say just another list of
liberals
anti-military
anti-big government
groups that are feeding
tim weiner of this information first of
all the information
they're feeding me
and helping me interpret are the records
of the government
all right
there's no spin on this
my approach to the problem
of secret spending
is that the constitution
calls for
a full accounting
of how the government spends our tax
money
and that
the black budget's growth and scope is a
challenge to that promise
i believe that we have
under
the veil of excessive secrecy
squandered a great deal of our national
treasure
on weaponry that will prove useless
and on
foreign policy schemes such as the iran
contra affair that have shamed our
nation
and that in the tug of war
between secrecy and democracy that we
need a little tug
back towards openness
here's the dedication page to herbert
and dora with love my parents
who taught me to love
words and ideas and language what do
they think of all this stuff that you're
involved in they're proud
they're proud i mean they write books
too
and uh it was my mother who's a
historian by profession who first
inculcated me with the value of digging
up documents
there's a i've got the new york times
from sunday right uh actually this is
being taped so this is sunday
september that let me find it here so
that those people would like to get
these 16th i believe you're right 16. um
36 billion worth of secrets
reviewed by lawrence corby used to be an
assistant secretary of defense now at
the brookings right
mr winer does an excellent job of
describing the history of the creation
of the black budget and pointing out the
abuses that can occur when public
disclosure is limited
blank check should be read for that
reason alone so far so good
uh then he says however
in too many places he undermines the
impact of his thesis with his simplistic
analysis for example
he treats all the abuses of the black
budget equally a group of army colonels
spending black budget money on hookers
personal trips and four-star hotels is
hardly a threat to our national security
and not on a par with the iran contra
affair yet both episodes get equal
treatment
well
with due respect to mr corb
i
tried to delineate a difference in the
book between the violation of law and
the violation of army regulations
in the first instance and a challenge to
the constitution of the united states in
the second interest
in the second in uh incidents the iran
contra
affair
i tried to make that delineation clear
and i'm sorry if i didn't make it clear
enough for him uh by the way how much
money is being spent for hookers and
four stars well this is this is um
this was a case
um in which the u.s army
tried to create
um a kind of a hard charging brigade of
secret soldiers it was going to be a
kind of a hybrid of the green beret and
the cia
and what happened was that this uh cadre
gained uh
access to
unauthorized funds
324 million dollars worth before they
were shut down
and you had a situation this is based on
records released through the freedom of
information act of the army's own
investigation of this affair
you had soldiers in mufti running around
with suitcases filled with cash
um
kind of running their own agenda
and the secretary of the army
uh
from 1981-89 john marsh
characterized the affair as
the precursor of the iran contra affair
um
i certainly don't mean to give the
impression that that the violations of
laws and army regulations these
gentlemen were
court-martialed in secret
um why
why were they court-martialed in secret
because their existence was supposed to
be a secret it was the first secret
court martial's courts martial i'm sorry
since vietnam in almost 20 years
i did not mean to convey the impression
that their violation of federal law and
army regulations
was equal to or greater than the
constitutional challenges that iran
contra presented what i did mean to
present
and the secretary of the army in that
era john marsh
says so himself as i quote him in my
book i did mean to present this incident
as a precursor to
the iran contra affair
one other line i want to ask you about
lawrence korb's review
by the way what did you think of the
review
i thought he was generous in places uh i
think that he has
every right to disagree with my analysis
i think that he is a wise gentleman and
that his ex his experience in the
pentagon
may
color his perception of my book
mr weiner mixes up so many questions in
his book
it will have less impact than his
articles well if it had an equal impact
to my articles and it was awarded the
kind of recognition the articles would
i'd be shocked myself
i think that
um well first of all i disagree that
i've conflated
questions of law or constitutionality or
of
government secrecy in this book
um
mr corb seems to suggest in his review
that
he concedes for example
yes too much is classified yes there
were too many blank checks in the reagan
administration yes
there needs to be greater disclosure
of what the government classifies as
secret
what he
seems to
want
is a kind of a convivial consensus
between the executive
and the legislative branches of
government
that will allow just the right amount of
secrecy
to protect our national security and
would
that
that could happen
but
it does not it is not the case there is
and will continue to be a struggle
between the desire
of the executive branch to
increase its powers under the national
security
um
vision
first framed in the early days of the
cold war
and the desire of elected
representatives for greater disclosure
um this is what makes democracy
a wonderful dog fight
it's this continuing tug of war
uh the uh
the vision of comity that will allow
just the right amount of secrecy
out that mr corbin visions is not the
way things are you wrote your newspaper
articles in 88 uh they were published in
87 in 87
you now have a book in 1990 right
uh you say you got a couple of prizes
one out of this particular one the
pulitzer prize has there been any other
tangible
result on that you know i hope so and i
would not attribute it to my articles
back in 87 but to
a slew
of other reporting by ai
cadre of
reporters
and to the iran contra investigation
itself i think that we go through cycles
of corruption and reform in this country
and that what happened
when the iran contra affair fell apart
was that we saw and this was the
conclusion of the majority report
of the iran contra committees
that
i believe their phrase was a cabal of
zealots
had stolen
a great deal of political power in this
country
and they attributed their theft of that
constitutional power to excessive
secrecy
um
i think that
that was an accurate analysis
and i think that now
as um
we
begin by consensus to push some of these
weapons programs into the light to
examine them for what they are
that
an intelligent result
will occur but you cannot argue about
stuff that's classified at the level
that the stealth bomber was you cannot
debate it and so decisions get made
um
without sufficient
information
programs tend to perpetuate themselves
without informed debate
how much of all of what you're talking
about in the black budget
should be kept secret no matter what
intelligence sources and methods
you don't want
for example to know that a head of state
is on the cia's payroll
are there many
well in the 70s jordan's king hussein
was on the cia's payroll
that's been publicly acknowledged by the
united states government
you
don't want to disclose
the ways in which
intelligence is gathered because that
will cut off the flow
of the intelligence
what you need to do given the economic
trouble we find ourselves in in this
country is to make intelligent choices
of how we spend our money
and
we cannot
write a blank check
to the pentagon or to the intelligence
agencies there has to be some level of
informed debate about the level of
spending
secret weapons and secret programs soak
up in this country let me give you an
example
i'm able to write about we're able to
discuss the stealth bomber because it's
been partly declassified after 10 years
of secret research and development now
we have at this hour as we speak on the
18th of september
a serious serious need
for
defense
strength in the persian gulf
the stealth bomber designed for nuclear
war against the soviet union is so
expensive that one of them would support
an entire division of troops in the
saudi desert for a year
you've got to have which costs how much
900 million dollars
you've got to be able to make
intelligent choices we're going around
the world with our hat in our hand
seeking money from foreign governments
to support this mission
because we have dedicated so much of our
treasure
so much of our brain power
to these highly
costly
dubiously
valued nuclear war technologies
we can now because of its
declassification debate whether we need
a stealth bomber
but there are a hundred other nuclear
war technologies buried in the black
budget
about which there can be no debate
a hundred others
related nuclear war technologies
give us an example
well one that's just peeking its nose
out into the light
is the milstar satellite system which i
write about at length and blank check
by the way before you explain that when
was the last word written for this book
the afterword was rewritten in may of
1990.
and previous to that when did you stop
writing the book about a year ago the
fall of
of 1989 and i made minor revisions for
clarity and uh as and updates
while the book was being edited by the
publisher why did it take so long to get
the book out it always takes nine months
uh from the from the submission of a
manuscript or it traditionally takes
nine months from the submission of a
manuscript to the uh
appearance of a book anybody ever tell
you why i heard that so often what's the
nine-month thing
it beats me it's a baffling process
perhaps it goes back to
the gestation of a fetus in the womb
we'll come back to milstar just a second
uh this book is published by warner
books correct at 21.95 correct if you
could have would you have changed
anything in here after what happened
over in the gulf
would that have any impact on i mean in
other words i'm getting that people who
buy this book today
will be out of date in any way
oh no i don't think so
um the the weapon systems that i discuss
in the book are weapon systems geared
for a full tilt nuclear war against the
soviet union those weapons systems still
exist they're still in the budget we
continue to build them as if the events
of the last 18 months had never happened
congress as we speak is weighing the
value
of these programs but i believe that
the information is fresh and the events
of the last six weeks in the persian
gulf in no way alter
the facts or the conclusions i'm sorry
mel starr okay
a classic example
of a military system developed under the
black budget it's now just been
declassified enough so that we can
discuss it intelligently
milstar is an acronym it's short for the
military strategic tactical and relay
system imagine the network as a
constellation of eight to ten satellites
in space in geosynchronous orbit 22 300
miles from earth
uh linked by three to four thousand
ground stations on earth kind of
computer terminals broadcast dishes
the purpose of milstar
is to enable
the survivors
of the national command authority the
president and his top military aides
the
survivors of the first days and weeks of
a nuclear war
to continue to broadcast the go codes
and launch orders
for the firing of nuclear weaponry after
the pentagon
after the white house
after washington after strategic america
air command headquarters in omaha are
destroyed
milstar would weave together our
fragmented forces so that the war
envisioned could continue in the united
states would emerge victorious from a
six-month
nuclear war that was the design
requirement under which milstar was
built
and its cost
once you include the cost of the rockets
to launch the satellites and the various
reconfigurations of the electronic
network
will be somewhere in the 30 to 40
billion dollar range why is it becoming
public
because it a is so expensive that it's
very difficult to hide in the black
budget the request for next year's
appropriation is more than a billion
dollars
to
it has to be sold because it is
controversial
because it is tremendously expensive it
has to be sold in the political
marketplace
it has to be sold to congress as a whole
this was the case with the strategic
defense in it initiative star wars star
wars was largely kept out of the black
world although some of its component
parts are very highly classified because
it was so radical in ocean
that it had to be sold in the political
marketplace this is why many people in
the pentagon don't like black programs
because you can't talk about them you
can't sell them
and
it it's
it's inimical to good science to have
compartmentalization
of different parts of a very complicated
military program
to have the people working on different
aspects of it
kept from talking to one another
former president james madison former
supreme court justice joseph story
former supreme court justice hugo black
former president dwight eisenhower
lord acton all of these people are
quoted throughout your book are you sure
you're not a political scientist rather
than a journalist never took a political
science course in my life why do you
love to
let me see if i can find the in the
opening pages here you use a quote from
hugo black the guarding of military and
diplomatic secrets at the expense of
informed representative government
provides no real security for our
republic
united states supreme court justice hugo
black from alabama who was also a
senator why did you quote him i couldn't
agree with him more first of all i see
second of all that
statement
comes from
one of the great confrontations in our
constitutional history
between the government and the press it
was the pentagon papers case
and the supreme court ruled
precisely as justice black
said that
if you're going to set up a balancing
test
between the guarding of official secrets
and the functioning of an informed
representative government you got to
give more weight to public information
and i think failure to follow that
dictate gets this nation into trouble
i forgot to mention one world famous uh
philosopher bill richardson
he gets a whole chapter chapter nine he
gets the bulk of the last chapter of the
book why
bill richardson is
a delightful man
now in his 70s
and a true patriot who became
the focus of one of the most interesting
and one of the least known supreme court
cases of the 1970s
bill
served this country
in world war ii and in the korean war
he served in various military
intelligence and communications
capacities
the man loves this country he knows the
value of secret intelligence
one day in 1967 he picked up his morning
paper and read that the cia
was funding student groups
subsidizing trade unions in this country
bill
knows how the cia is supposed to work
and bill knows his constitution
and he thought correctly the cia was
violating its charter
bill picked up um put down the newspaper
and sat down to his typewriter and wrote
a letter to the secretary of the
treasury to the department of the
treasury and to the bureau of the budget
and said
i believe
that i have a right as a citizen a
taxpayer and a voter to know how my
money is being spent and i'd like to see
a copy of the cia's budget
they wrote back to him and said mr
richardson we don't have it
he
after extended correspondence went down
to the federal courthouse in pittsburgh
near where he lived and filed a very
well drawn up lawsuit
against the federal government seeking
the information he believed he had a
right to have
he was opposed in court by the then
united states attorney in western
pennsylvania richard thornberg now the
attorney general of the united states
in the district court he lost he
appealed
he went to the federal appeals court and
he won
the appeals court sitting on bank
meaning every sitting justice in the
appeals court heard the case because it
addressed here thereto for unresolved
question of federal law
what appeals court again that's the
third circuit sitting in philadelphia
said that richardson did have the right
to this information
and that the constitution promised it to
him
and that he as a citizen and a voter in
a taxpayer
had the absolute right to seek the
information promised him
that decision came down in 1971
when
government secrecy in this country was
at its zenith
and government deception in this country
was at its height
that deception eventually resulted in
the resignation of a president
the government sat up and took judicial
notice
of mr richardson's victory in the
appeals court
and appealed
the decision it went to the supreme
court
in 1973 robert bork was then the
solicitor general
the case the decision in the case came
down in 74
right before richard nixon's resignation
richardson lost 5-4
just chief justice berger writing the
majority opinion said look
the united states is not an athenian
democracy it is not a new england town
meeting and we don't have to listen to
every tom dick and harry
with a constitutional
beef justice douglas in a fiery descent
said richardson has the right to this
information and by denying it to him by
a five to four vote
we give a new and premature
to government secrecy to excessive
government secrecy
in many ways i wrote this book for
william richardson where is he today
he's living in greensburg pennsylvania
and what's he doing
he's uh reading he's in retirement he's
72 i guess
and he is continuing to think
about the issues that he raised long ago
for every famous victory in the supreme
court there are a hundred people like
bill richardson how did you find him
by knowing the case how'd you know the
case
it's a classic in the confrontation
between
excessive secrecy and the democracy
promised by the constitution our guest
for the last hour has been the author of
this book blank check the pentagon's
black budget his name is tim weiner and
he works for the philadelphia enquirer
and is based here in washington it's
been a pleasure thank you thank you sir
[Music]
next week on booknotes we bring you a
conversation with political economist
pat chout
he joins us to discuss the theories
presented in his most recent book agents
of influence how japan's lobbyists in
the united states manipulate america's
political and economic system
that's book notes with pat choat next
sunday night at eight o'clock eastern
time
[Music]
at the end of each week the top news
stories are reviewed by a group of
journalists and c-span viewers
tune in for a re-air of the